[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم معكم سهام قشطه لنستعرض معا
ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز وضمن
ابرز الاحداث خطه اكواز لتدخل العسكري في
النيجر السويد تستنفر امنيا بعد الاعتداء
على المصحف نيمار وبونو الى السعوديه
لنبدا من النيجر التي تتارجح فيها الازمه
بين خيارين الدبلوماسيه او التدخل العسكري
لنسال زميلنا جعفر سلامات جعفر مشهد معقد
في النيجر وخيارات صعبه الذي يجري هناك
نعم تطورات متسارعه سهام شهدتها النيجر
خلال الايام الماضيه بدايه بعزم قاده
الانقلاب على محاكمه الرئيس محمد بازوم
والخطوه الانتقادات الدوليه واسعه هناك
ايضا جهود دبلوماسيه متسارعه حيث وفد من
علماء دين من نيجيريا التقوا قاده
الانقلاب بينما وضع قاده جيوش دول مجموعه
ايكواس السيره النهائيه للتدخل العسكري
وقال قالوا ان هدفه هو استعاده النظام
الدستوري شكرا
الله اكبر
الغربيه لم يتوقف خلال الاسبوع الماضي حيث
استشهد فلسطينيين في اقتحام لقوات
الاحتلال لمخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا كما
اغتالت قائدا في كتائب الاقصى في منزله
بمخيم جنين وقصفت المنزله بعد الانسحاب
منه اما في ملف الاسرى الفلسطينيين فقد
اعلن عدد منهم اضرابا عن الطعام بعد زياره
بن جبير لسجن عوفر ودعوته لزياده التضييق
عليهم لكن هل يمكن ان يغير اضراب الاسرى
من سياسات الحكومه الاسرائيليه بحقهم عن
هذا نسال رئيس الهيئه العليا لمتابعه شؤون
الاسرى والمحررين امين الشومان
سيد امين اذا اضرابه للاسرى الفلسطينيين
هل يمكن في اعتقادك ان يغير شيئا يعني من
المؤكد لا تماما ان هذا الاضراب الجماعي
والمفطوع عن الطعام سيؤثر بشكل كبير جدا
على هذه السياسات التي تنتهجها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بحرق الاسرى والاسيرات داخل
السجون المعتقلات الاسرائيليه وخاصه بعد
الزياره الاستفزازيه التي قام بها ابن
جفير لسجني النقب وعوفر وما تلا ذلك من
نقل تعسفي للاسرى والذي بناء عليه تم دخول
الاسرى في اضراب جماعي مفتوح عن الطعام
مما يشكل ضغطا شعبيا وجماهريا على هذه
الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه لتغيير سياساتها
تجاه الحركه الاسيره داخل السجون
والمعتقلات الاسرائيليه
من المصحف الشريف في السويد السلطات ترفع
مستوى التاهب لوقوع هجمات الى ثاني اعلى
درجاته في حين اكدت رئيسه جهاز الامن ان
الوضع الامني في البلاد ساء في اعقاب
حوادث حرق نسخ من المصحف الشريف زمنا مع
تحذير كل من بريطانيا والولايات المتحده
رعايهما من السفر الى السويد رفع مستوى
تهديد الامني في السويد اثار غضبا واسعا
بين الناشطين لنلقي نظره على ابرز
تفاعلاتكم ابو بكر رحيم قال اول ليس
الاولى للسويد منع ما يجلب الضرر حرق نسخ
من المصحف ليس حريه وانما هو ظلم وتعد على
الاخر ومقدساته فراجعوا تشريعاتكم
وقوانينكم حتى تحترم كل الناس
بينما تساءلت الجنين قائله الا يعتبر حرق
المصحف ارهابا ايتها الدوله المتقدمه
المتحضره الى واقعه اثرت جدلا واسعا حيث
اعلنت زامبيا احتجاز طائره خاصه قادمه من
القاهره واعتقال عشره اشخاص كانوا على
متنها السلطات قالت ان الطائره كانت تحمل
خمسه ملايين دولار ومسدسات وسبائك من
الذهب قبل ان تتراجع لتعلن ان السبائك من
النحاس والنيكل اما في الرد المصري فقالت
القاهره ان طائره ليست مصريه وانها تنسق
مع الزامبيا للوقوف على حقيقه الواقع
حرائق الغابات فيها هواي الامريكيه ومشاهد
الدمار الواسع الذي خلفته تصدرت المشهد
خلال الاسبوع الماضي مع اعلان السلطات
ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا الى اكثر من 100
قتيل وستوقعات بارتفاع ماساوي لعددهم في
حين طلب السكان باجراء تحقيق في فشل اطلاق
سفارات الانذار المبكر في الحرائق التي
لم تكن الوحيده التي عانت من تداعيات
التغير المناخي الحاد حيث شهدت تدوال
عربيه عده موجه حر شديده في التعليقات
تجدون فيديو يوضح لكم تفاصيل الموجه
الاستثنائيه الان الى اخبار الرياضه
وتحديدا في السعوديه حيث تعقد نادي الهلال
رسميا مع كل من النجم البرازيلي نيمار
قادما من باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي لمده
موسمين وحارس منتخب المغرب وفريق اشبيليه
الاسباني ياسين بونو لثلاث سنوات تفاصيل
الصفقتين لم يكشف عنها لكن وسائل اعلام
ذكرت ان قيمه عقد انتقال نيمار الى الهلال
وصلت الى 100 مليون يورو نرحب هنا في
الاستوديو بالزميل عمار النامق مرحبا عمار
مساء الخير كريستيانو رونالدو كريم بنزيما
نيمار رياض محرز وغيره من النجوم باتو في
صفوف الانديه السعوديه كيف سيرفع هؤلاء من
حده التنافس في الدوري السعودي في اعتقاده
هذه الاسماء كانك تتحدثي عن دوري انجليزي
ولا دوري الم فعلا هذه الاسماء الكبيره
كلها صارت في السعوديه يرفع التنافس ليس
فقط في السعوديه وانما حتى الدول المحيطه
انا متاكد انه الدوريات ستبدا بحله جديده
من كل يعني دول الخليج هذه من العراق الى
عمان سيتغير مفهوم الدوري وسيستم الدوري
الاسماء الكبيره هذه بكل تاكيد ستساهم في
تنشيط كره القدم في هذه البلدان يعني
تصوري انت لاعبه وفي بدايه التجربه
وتلعبين مع نيمار ولا مع بنزيما ولا مع
الاسماء الكبيره فاكيد هناك ثوره وهناك
تغيير جذري في في مفهوم الدوري وفي
المستوى وفي الاعداد الذهني والبدني
شكرا لك على هذه المعلومات اذا مشاهدينا
كان هذا ايجاز هذا الاسبوع نلتقي الاسبوع
المقبل في انجاز جديد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]